This episode has been supported by Lambda
Labs.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Let’s talk about a great recent development
in image translation!
Image translation means that some image goes
in, and it is translated into an analogous
image of a different class.
A good example of this would be when we have
a standing tiger as an input, and we ask the
algorithm to translate this image into the
same tiger lying down.
This leads to many amazing applications, for
instance, we can specify a daytime image and
get the same scene during nighttime.
We can go from maps to satellite images, from
video games to reality and more.
However, much like many learning algorithms
today, most of these techniques have a key
limitation - they need a lot of training data,
or in other words, these neural networks require
seeing a ton of images in all of these classes
before they can learn to meaningfully translate
between them.
This is clearly inferior to how humans think,
right?
If I would show you a horse, you could easily
imagine, and some of you could even draw what
it would look like if it were a zebra instead.
As I am sure you have noticed by reading arguments
on many internet forums, humans are pretty
good at generalization.
So, how could we possibly develop a learning
technique that can look at very few images,
and obtain knowledge from them that generalizes
well?
Have a look at this crazy new paper from scientists
at NVIDIA that accomplishes exactly that.
In this example, they show an input image
of a golden retriever, and then, we specify
the target classes by showing them a bunch
of different animal breeds, and…look!
In goes your golden, and out comes a pug or
any other dog breed you can think of..
And now, hold on to your papers, because this
AI doesn’t have access to these target images
and it had only seen them the very first time
as we just gave it to them.
It can do this translation with previously
unseen object classes.
How is this insanity even possible?
This work contains a generative adversarial
network, which assumes that the training set
we give it contains images of different animals,
and what it does during training is practicing
the translation process between these animals.
It also contains a class encoder that creates
a low-dimensional latent space for each of
these classes, which means that it tries compress
these images down to a few features that contain
the essence of these individual dog breeds.
Apparently it can learn the essence of these
classes really well because it was able to
convert our image into a pug without ever
seeing a pug other than this one target image.
As you can see here, it comes out way ahead
of previous techniques, but of course, if
we give it a target image that is dramatically
different than anything the AI has seen before,
it may falter.
Luckily, you can even try it yourself through
this web demo which works on pets, so make
sure to read the instructions carefully, and,
let the experiments begin!
In fact, due to popular request, let me kick
this off with Lisa, my favorite chihuahua.
I got many tempting alternatives, but worry
not, in reality, she will stay as is.
I was also curious about trying a non-traditional
head position, and as you see with the results,
this was a much more challenging case for
the AI.
The paper also discusses this limitation in
more detail.
You know the saying, two more papers down
the line, and I am sure this will also be
remedied.
I am hoping that you will also try your own
pets and as a Fellow Scholar, you will flood
the comments section here with your findings.
Strictly for science, of course.
If you’re doing deep learning, make sure
to look into Lambda GPU systems.
Lambda offers workstations, servers, laptops,
and a GPU cloud for deep learning.
You can save up to 90% over AWS, GCP, and
Azure GPU instances.
Every Lambda GPU system is pre-installed with
TensorFlow, PyTorch, and Keras.
Just plug it in and start training.
Lambda customers include Apple, Microsoft,
and Stanford.
Go to lambdalabs.com/papers or click the link
in the description to learn more.
Big thanks to Lambda for supporting Two Minute
Papers and helping us make better videos.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!